y en directo América ahora hablamos de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge
bienvenido vamos a iniciar este segmento
con el dato de inflación en la eurozona
Así es bueno la inflación ahí se moderó
ligeramente Aunque hay otro dato que es
el que más está preocupando los
economistas la inflación anual de
febrero ahí fue del 8,5% anual frente al
8,6% de enero con esta baja se acumulan
cinco meses consecutivos cediendo según
mostraron los datos que divulga la
oficina comunitaria estadísticas
eurostat lo que más subió fue la
alimentación bebidas alcohólicas y
tabaco que registró en febrero un máximo
del 15% seguido de la energía con un
13,7%, pero el dato que más preocupa es
la inflación subyacente una medida que
excluye el efecto de los elementos más
volátiles como la energía y los
alimentos y ese dato escaló hasta un
récord del 5,6% anual estas cifras
podrán dar una idea al Banco Central
europeo sobre su decisión de mantener
las subidas de los tipos de interés que
comenzaron en julio para intentar
mantener los precios bajo control
bueno Y en medio de esta fuerte
inflación también en Egipto el gobierno
subió el precio de algunos tipos de
gasolina bueno el Ministerio de petróleo
informó en un comunicado que subía el
precio de las mezclas de gasolina normal
media y Súper este aumento podría ser
subir los precios de otros bienes y
servicios en todo Egipto sin embargo el
precio del diesel Que es el combustible
más utilizado para el transporte de
personas sin mercancías en Egipto no se
verá afectado Egipto tiene una inflación
anual del 26,5% en enero la más alta en
5 años según la cifras oficiales pero
los precios de los alimentos en algunas
zonas urbanas se disparan hasta cerca
del 48% la economía egipcia se ve
afectada principalmente por años de
austeridad gubernamental la pandemia y
las secuelas de la guerra en Ucrania del
país actualmente es el mayor importador
de trigo del mundo y la mayor parte de
sus importaciones proceden
tradicionalmente de Europa del este
Jorge y Hablamos ahora de América Latina
el presidente de Brasil relanzó el
programa bolsa familia bueno según los
planes pretende aliviar la pobreza
extrema en 55 millones de personas según
el Gobierno Federal la familia
beneficiarias recibirían un monto mínimo
de 600 reais unos 115 dólares
estadounidenses y se crearán dos
beneficios complementarios Lula prometió
dar 150 reais adicionales o sea unos 29
Dólares por cada niño menor de 6 años
este nuevo bolsa familia entrará en
vigor cuando se publique en el diario
oficial pero deberá ser aprobado en un
plazo de 120 días por el Congreso
Nacional la bolsa familia fue una de las
grandes promesas de campaña para
enfrentar la pobreza pero la medida ha
sido criticada por la oposición que
argumenta que este tipo de ayudas
oficiales no tienen los resultados
esperados el nuevo bolsa familia estará
dotado con unos
33.650 millones de dólares cifra
equivalente acerca del uno coma cinco
por ciento del producto inter no
brasileño y se calcula que va a
beneficiar al menos a 60 millones de
personas poco más el 30% de la población
escuchemos parte del anuncio del
presidente brasileño
está prometiendo no estamos prometiendo
que bolsa familia vaya a resolver todos
los problemas de la sociedad brasileña
es el primer plato de sopa el primer
plato de frijoles el primer vaso de
leche la primera barra de panel el
primer trozo de carne pero junto a eso
tiene que venir una política de
crecimiento económico
bueno medidas a las que se había
comprometido en campaña y vamos a
cambiar de tema porque el precio de las
viviendas en Estados Unidos está pasando
por un punto de inflexión luego de años
en aumentos Así es en Las cuatro semanas
transcurridas hasta el 26 de febrero el
precio medio de una vivienda en Estados
Unidos Fue de $350,000 un 0,6% menos que
en el mismo periodo del año anterior
Esto se debe al aumento del costo de los
préstamos que frenó el mercado
inmobiliario ralentizando las ventas
Aunque la caída de los precios podría
suponer un alivio para los consumidores
el aumento de los tipos de interés está
limitando que las personas puedan
acceder a estos créditos y la falta de
viviendas también en venta podría
limitar la caída de los precios para los
analistas Es probable que esos precios
bajen un poco más en los próximos meses
Aunque tampoco habrá grandes ofertas
para los compradores primerizos los
tipos hipotecarios casi duplican los del
mismo periodo del año pasado un sondeo
realiza
mostró que la media para un préstamo a
tipo fijo y a 30 años superaba el 7% en
ese país pues con razón estamos viendo
estas cifras Jorge usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación económica nosotros
los dejamos con mi compañero Santiago
López y el debate